on s'en souvient le 24 septembre dernier
on avait diffusé des extraits de
l'interview de la grand mère maternelle
d'alexandre et de yann moix cette
affaire voilà qui nous tient en haleine
depuis le début de la saison
cette interview c'est vous qui l'aviez
réaliser on a appris qu alexandre moix
le frère de yann moix a décidé de vous
poursuivre en justice pour affirmation
mensongère et diffamatoire la raison il
estime que l'interview prenait la
défense de son frère yann moix
il aurait d'ailleurs demandé un droit de
réponse à ces huit qu'il n'y aurait pas
été accordé on a quelques extraits de la
lettre rédigée par alexandre moix à
vomir dans un instant et on attend de
votre réponse bien sûr eric naulleau
c'est vrai que c'est complètement fou
cette histoire et moi je voulais juste
dire un truc à alexandre moix c'est que
pour répondre déjà et qui dit que ces
huit ne lui a pas laissé un droit de
réponse
sachez qu'on a envoyé alexandre mode des
textos pour qu'il vienne dans l'émission
la seule fois on pouvait l'interviewer
il nous a dit qu'il fallait qu'on voie
parce qu' il fallait qu'on voie avec son
agent je pense pas qu'il fallait on paye
et ils interviewent n'aurait même pas
été réalisés par nos journalistes mais
par un de ses amis est donc finalement
c'est son avocat qui a été très sympa
qui est venu voilà mais lui a toujours
refusé de venir puisqu'on avait invité
je vous le dis le 2 septembre m emmanuel
pierrât qui était son avocat et je crois
qu'il est toujours donc voilà donc ces
huit ou lui avait donné un droit de
réponse qui n'a pas voulu s'octroyer
donc à nos frères de yann moix qui vous
cherche des noises
voilà apparemment il veut vous attaquez
le fira le frère de yann moix est ce
qu'on a résumé de la faire ou pas tout
puisque j'ai plus aucune fiche il ya cet
abruti de castaldi qui ajoutés tout est
fichu par terre
est-ce qu'on a un résumé ou pas de
l'histoire s'il vous plaît aux régies
tulle et rénaux ou bien regardant on
lance merci machine on y va on n'a pas
des quatre maires sont va très bien
alors donc alexandre moi qui voulais pas
qu'on lui dise merci joseph heureusement
que tu es là
alors non qui vous attaquent en justice
n'a pris donc une nouvelle vous
concernant et il dit que voilà que vous
avez fait l'interview de sa grand-mère
et qu'apparemment uhs i still il estime
que l'interview prenait la défense de
son fonds de vote de son frère donc yann
moix
il aurait d'ailleurs demandé un droit de
réponse ou l'a dit tout à l'heure que
j'avais donnés tous les droits des
albinos qui voulait qu'il n'a pas pris
donc qu'est ce que vous avez à lui
répond eh bien d'abord c'est un peu
surpris parce que dans cette lettre y
montre pas mal d'inquiétudes envers sa
grand mère mais moi quand j'étais
l'interview de la grammaire elle n'avait
plus de nouvelles de lui
que ce soit des visites ou des coups de
téléphone depuis des années donc je suis
content qu'ils s'intéressent de nouveau
à sa grand mère mais ça me paraît un peu
opportuniste
ensuite dans sa lettre il ya des propos
assez diffamatoires à mon endroit donc
on verra la suite que je lui donne moi
même quand il dit que l'interview était
téléguidé par yann moix moi la personne
qui m'a servi d'intermédiaire c'est
également elle qui m'a accompagnée chez
la grand-mère de yann moix de yann moix
et d'alexandre notes et yann moix qui
n'était pas présent enfin ce qu'il
conteste comme point je crois savoir que
c'est assez bien documenté et je sais
pas s'il a intérêt à faire une action en
justice où ces documents seraient
produits je pense qu'ils pourraient s'en
mordre les doigts
mais encore une fois la décision lui
appartient alors aux qu'il aurait pu
s'abstenir de ce nouvel épisode vole
alors ses huit nous a dit là un instant
est un instant qu'il avait demandé donc
un droit de réponse sur ces 8 mai que sa
demande n'était pas conforme
juridiquement donc ils y ont refusé
voilà en tout cas on va voir et s'il
veut venir vous seriez prêt à on parle
avec lui vous sur l'événement évidemment
sans problème s'il veut venir maintenant
on l'a invité plein de fois il n'a
jamais voulu venir
on voit là s'il veut venir s'expliquer
avec eric naulleau il est bien venu sur
le plateau de touche pas à mon poste
avec cette histoire dont on parle encore
à travailler encore avec le livre de
yann moix